- Vlog, this is a fairly uneventful
vlog.
Babin, we're gonna have to figure out
some random shit right now, which we will.
I'll come up with some
crazy rant but first,
(hip-hop beat)
(upbeat electronic beat)
Hey guys, good morning.
Here in Houston, big ups, congrats to the
Astros, big championship,
what up Little Lou.
Full day with clients.
We made bunch of phone calls,
all internal Vayner, VaynerMedia stuff.
Show Jeff real quick, he hates it.
Jeff Nicholson, our
incredible Chief Media Officer
and I got a lot of work
done on the flight out here
for a 6:00 a.m. flight,
that was pretty epic.
I actually think the air--
Actually vlog, airport hack.
I think more people should take flights
just to have meetings and then leave.
Like sometimes, that's our y-positive.
We'll do it much more on the way back.
Great holiday weekend, life is good,
super pumped how well the
Permission video is doing.
What permission are you looking for?
I'm just so tired of, you know,
so many people are using me right now
to give them permission to do stuff
and it is my literally, my literally
greatest feeling of my life.
If you haven't seen it, check it out.
Very fired up about today's Cyber Monday.
I know you guys are seeing
this Wednesday or Tuesday,
I don't know what you guys are doing but,
Cyber Monday offer on my
new book, Crushing It,
it's gonna be phenomenal.
Big Cyber Monday deal going on today.
If you're planning on
buying Crushing It, my book,
today is the day to do it.
I'm doing a buy five books,
get entered into a contest.
Five of you are getting,
five of you are getting dinner
with me in New York City.
And just a lot of themes, right?
You know, you saw Cyber Monday and
well, I'm already assuming it.
You know, Black Friday and I
assume today on Cyber Monday,
just incredible, dominant maneuvering to
retail happening online and communication
and your media consumption patterns,
you know the internet
is eating up the world
and you need to be on the
right side of that history.
Working on 003, the sneaker launch,
this is just a little bit of an update,
working on a couple secret projects
that I can't tell you about,
and just you know, a day
in the life of a CEO of
of a 800 person holding company.
Today, got some pure wow
stuff for the gallery
on the VaynerX world,
tons of VaynerMedia stuff,
just unlimited VaynerMedia stuff.
More about our capability of what partner
we bring in above the line.
Make a quick phone call
to my dad and Brandon
about Wine Library stuff as
they go into their core season.
And also, the white label Harold
and the Robert Craig in the 'Con Valley,
I would go hard at that.
Just trying to up my game, a lotta,
a lot of engagement on Instagram lately.
Babin's excited about all
these 100,000 like plus posts.
You guys look like the Beatles.
It's like the fuckin'
Beatles are walking by.
Anyway, gotta go.
Big meeting here in Houston,
that's what I'm here for.
Babin's here. B-A-B-I-N on Instagram.
Better than D-Rock,
slightly worse than Iris.
(laughing)
- How you doing Gary Vee?
- How are you doing man?
- Michael.
- Michael, with pleasure.
- Sorry to bother you but
I got a quick question.
- Now worries, sure go ahead.
You got it?
- What's one good tip that you can give
to a young entrepreneur that's
trying to grow his business?
As far as on the training side?
- On the training side?
I think it's content man.
You gotta get out there.
You gotta get people
here to know who you are
so they ask for you.
I think Instagram is ridiculous.
Like how often are you
posting on Instagram?
Honestly.
- Honestly, I try,
of myself or just about knowledge
in general, information?
- Information or you
know, you looking good,
but posts on Instagram on
your Instagram account?
- At least two times a day.
- Good, I would go to four.
- Four times a day.
Just content or just workout
videos and information?
- The more you give them,
you know, and listen,
a good shot of you
looking good is for them
but like more about
them than you about you.
- Okay.
- And then, you gotta be smart about it.
So for example, I'm about
to post this video about
hashtags, like really
being smart about hashtags.
Like when you post, you need to post,
the first comment needs
to have 20, 30 hashtags.
- I have that.
- Good.
- I have all my hashtags
already saved or whatever.
- Now the next thing.
You gotta go, you gotta search hashtags
like fitness, things of
that nature in your radius,
so within a 20 mile radius of this place.
Let me show you.
So like literally, you go into here
and you type in fitness,
right?
And you go into the tags,
right and you hit that.
- Okay.
- Right?
- Right.
- And now, you need to like
look at people's stuff,
really consume it and
then leave a comment like,
"Yo bro, that's doing it right."
- Got you.
- You need to become
part of the community,
not just pushing out.
- Got you.
- If you go hard, four
times a day, shit for them.
You go into 90 accounts
a day and leave your,
you know, that's you laying
in bed in the morning
or like fuckin', right
now, you're a little early,
yeah, exactly, grab a
coffee or whatever you do
and like, you do that--
Honestly, as I've gotten my fitness up
in the last couple years,
it's the same shit you know about fitness.
There's no shortcut.
There's no shortcut,
and there's no steroids in this.
You know, like, there's no shortcut.
It's just fuckin' everyday
eating, like you know,
some people are like, what's happening,
you're not eating right or you're not,
I've all of a sudden finally figured out
how to use my lats so my
shoulders aren't hurting
and I'm finally starting
to build, you know?
- I got you.
- It's that.
Discipline.
- Discipline, four times a
day, consistent, got you.
- Go into the community.
- Okay.
Appreciate it my man.
If I could get a quick photo with you--
- Yeah, sure, of course.
- I greatly appreciate it.
- Wish you well brother.
Take care, have a great holiday.
Here's, here's Justine and Mark Evans.
They are now here.
So now we are going to go and attack.
YouTube, YouTube,
YouTube, I love you guys.
Please subscribe if you haven't.
Would mean the world to me
and I appreciate all your comments,
read a bunch of them over Thanksgiving,
enjoyed the shit out of it.
On my way to Equinox for a shower
'cause that's how I do it.
Texans fan.
And let's go.
(upbeat electronic beat)
Vlog, this is a fairly uneventful vlog.
Babin, we're gonna have to figure out
some random shit right now, which we will.
I'll come up with some
crazy rant, but first,
your favorite moment.
Vlog, one of the great
things about this vlog
is the memes, right?
Like the fake or is it rivalry
between Babin and D-Rock.
But the best meme, no question,
is the incredible nature
of the greatest superhero
we've ever seen really.
I mean like, really, the
greatest, I mean listen,
I'm a big fan of Batman.
Like I understand Spider-Man
and Superman and Thor's
intrigue and amazing abs and biceps
but has there ever been a
superhero more exciting for
2018 entrepreneurs than the one and only,
one of the great, and I mean great
entrepreneurs of this generation,
hustle coming out of all parts of his body
and that's just how we do it.
- We made it baby.
- We made it baby, tell 'em.
- G5 mofuckin' airplane, big dick baby.
(laughing)
- Pleasure man.
- Pleasure.
- Airport Gary.
Now you know why he's
such a great superhero.
'Cause he deals with content
of all kinds at all times
and never wavers baby.
Airport Gary.
(laughing)
That was incredible.
Guys, knowing that this is gonna be,
a content thin episode,
think it's super important to
bang out a little rant,
give you some value.
One thing that might have
hit and missed your radar
that I wanna get in here,
I think a bunch of you saw it
but I'm seeing huge results.
Some of the fastest
feedback I've ever seen
is around this $1.80 strategy.
90 posts on Instagram
leaving your two cents
becoming part of the community
for growth and content,
super fascinating.
If you don't know what I'm talking about,
let's link down below Babin.
I'm sure we've posted it on
Facebook and YouTube by now.
Your $1.80 strategy is incredible.
One of the biggest things
that so many of you've missed
is everybody talks about content, right.
What content, what content, what content.
Nobody's talking about community.
You know, context of the content matters
but community.
The three C's right?
Like content of course,
we all talk about it.
Context, which is the thing that I think
I've been teaching you which is what
kind of creative and what platform.
But community, something I wrote in
Thank You Economy in 2011,
is just like super duper, duper--
- Gary Vee.
- Hey man, how are you?
- Recording your video?
- Yeah you're in it now.
You're in it bro.
You're in it.
Community.
Community really, really,
really, really matters
and this $1.80 strategy
is one of the more unique,
clever ways that I've come up with it.
Have you seen it yet Babin?
I'm pumped about it.
Check it.
Double down on the $1.80.
Shit, go $3.60.
While this is gonna be a
funnier kind of episode,
let's settle once and for all.
You know, Babin, D-Rock, Kyle,
Justin, Iris, right?
Those are the five that
have really done it?
Why don't you edit up a scene,
two scenes that are six seconds each,
so that's 12 times five,
sixty seconds, two scenes,
now you gotta be fair 'cause
it's you, Babin, in it,
so have you have to be fair or don't.
Two scenes, six seconds
each, from all five
and in the comment section,
vote for you favorite production editor,
predator, producer, director, of DailyVee.
- You just started the World War 3.
- I mean look, D-Rock has
a disproportion advantage
for being around for a long time.
You have this whole kind of
like, underbelly cult following,
Iris has won over a lot of
hearts, she's really skilled.
Justin disadvantage for being around,
being gone for a little while.
Hi, how are you?
My
leave that there,
I couldn't print my ticket
'cause there was some adjustments,
Justin disadvantaged it
for being away for so long
and Kyle's new but has a crazy mustache.
Chop it up.
Give us answers.
So it's early Monday morning,
and I've been wanting to
make a Monday morning video
for a long time and finally
D-Rock, we're doing it.
So real quick, this is just a rant.
(hip-hop music)
Congrats, you're in fuckin' debt.
(laughing)
You need to be more better
Homes and Garden and less QVC.
Got it?
- Thank you so much.
You're welcome, take care.
- Gary, love your wine show.
- Thank you so much man.
I appreciate that.
How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you man.
Babin here is all bent out of shape.
He just said today is rough.
To be very frank with you VaynerNation,
I don't give a f--
Alright, big night for
D-Rock, Babin fucked up.
New K-Swiss sneakers and Babin literally
forgot the sneakers at the office.
This morning, I don't
know if we caught it Iris,
I don't think so, I told Tyler like
bringing the fuckin' sneakers to the shoot
for the shoot of the fuckin' sneakers.
Babin.
- He told me and I--
- It would been good if you figured it out
19 minutes ago instead of--
And I mean that, it's like
I think the real reason
I give away my content for free,
I engage with all of you,
I answer, I give love,
I think the biggest reason I do that
is 'cause I don't need your help or money
to accomplish my goals.
I think it's the ultimate leverage
to be able to give more
and always give more
and always give more.
And learn how to take, not at the expense
of the people you're giving--
And I'm starting to find a little clarity.
Starting to understand
why this thing is so hard.
This game of entrepreneurship.
Shit, this game of life.
It's because the real
answer is really found
when you're pulling from
opposite directions.
Sitting here laying and saying, why?
Why, why am I so blessed?
Why is all this good stuff happening?
And it's because I'm a contradiction.
You know, I knew that what
I was doing in business,
what I was doing in friendship,
what I was doing in parenting,
like that was all on point.
But in the back of my mind,
I knew that my health wasn't there right?
But the way I was rolling,
I should've looked a thousand times worse
than I looked back then, right?
Like, my weight and just my body structure
and my natural DNA kept it in check enough
that I wasn't 400 pounds because
there was no good eating habits,
there was zero, I mean basically,
there was zero exercising,
zero until the time I was 38
and a half when I did this
so it's on the back of my
mind since I turned 30.
(upbeat electronic beat)